côté à la fois par l'imprudence de
certains et par une longue période de
sécheresse le terrible incendie a ravagé
les forêts de pins de la côte des mots
chaque été les mêmes images oad les
habitants et les estivants ont dû
évacuer les villages menacés des fours
est en feu et dès les années 70 la
sécheresse est pointé du doigt avec la
sécheresse qui ne fait que s'accentuer
la situation devient aujourd'hui
alarmant des était de plus en plus chaud
partout en france et déjà des
inquiétudes avec cette sécheresse les
incendies qui était jusqu'à lors le
triste privilège des forêts
méditerranéennes ou landaise s'étendent
maintenant à l'ensemble de la france
bretagne vosges et région parisienne
sont à leur tour touchés ce constat fait
en 1976 se répétera année après année
entre 1960 et 2008 les feux de forêt ont
augmenté de 18% mais il faudra attendre
les années 2000 pour que certains
scientifiques fassent le lien entre
augmentation du nombre de feux de forêt
et réchauffement climatique eh bien
écoutez ce qui est certain c'est que à
la fois la fréquence et l'amplitude des
incendies et des feux qu'on appelle
catastrophe est amené à s'accroître
notablement
2019 année record rien que pour le
département du gard 1200 départ de feu
les scientifiques étaient déjà
convaincus l'état à son tour fait le
entre changement climatique et
augmentation du nombre de feux de forêts
l'ampleur le nombre de départements et
l'ampleur du territoire touché c'est
vraiment une situation exceptionnelle
c'est probablement lié au réchauffement
climatique global et au dérèglement
climatique donc on peut s'attendre à ce
que ça se reproduisent des feux de
forêts plus intenses pendant des
périodes plus longues allant du
printemps à l'automne et concernant plus
de régions c'est aussi la conclusion de
jean jouzel quand on regarde les cartes
de risques de feux de forêts en france
en raison de 1050 des régions comme le
centre et l'ouest de la france qui ne
sont pas à risque actuellement le
deviendrai par rapport aux feux de forêt
donc en gros ça va effectivement le ces
risques devront s'étendre dans d'autres
régions de france si le réchauffement
climatique n'est pas maîtrisée d'autant
plus que ces feux de forêt participent
au réchauffement climatique en dégageant
de la pollution un cercle vicieux qui ne
semble pas prendre fin cette année
[Musique]